they are truly amazing I am like
astonished that everything that they all
came and they're so excited and that
makes me excited and I mean I think the
fans are the reason why this movie
exists why it does well so it's it's
amazing I love them
yeah it does
every every single aspect of the story
and of the characters and their
respective lives are are there they're
more intricate there is more drama the
it's tightened intensity and it's it's
it's pretty cool
[Music]
yeah and I think that's what truly draws
people to the film is these people
Anastasia and Christian just severely
loved each other and they and they let
it happen and that is a beautiful thing
to watch unfold is it so much fun yeah I
mean it's it's it's wild I am everyday
kind of like wet I did what but it's
it's so exciting
[Music]
yes it's a it's a weird thing I've never
really revisited a project or a
character before so it's very
interesting to have like my personal
growth and and also Jamie's personal
growth between projects and then we come
back together and our lives are
different and like he has another baby
and I don't well I think there's a theme
there's sort of this fairy tale theme
throughout all three films and it's sort
of a dream world but these very real
people exist within it and I think
that's what makes it sort of captivating
and also relatable it's true no it's
true the funds you know they're big
massive you know vitally important part
of this whole process and these these
books before the movies and other movies
and on our journey of it and to see
their appreciation of it is it's huge
man it's it's it's like we're doing it
for them you know we want people to
watch a movie too aren't necessarily
only fans of the you know the stories
but you know they're undeniably
important in
you know and very much in our thoughts
they're like making it you know because
they really really care about this you
know so yeah they're very important yeah
I think that's right yeah and there's
new characters here introduced to out a
bit of darkness to it and a bit of drama
to it and a bit of tension too and make
it a bit of a thriller I think in
aspects which we see a you know further
development of in fread next year when
we get to see that but um yeah it's
definitely darker elements and it's just
uh you know development of their
relationship and we see a lot of stuff
up in the laughing we see a lot of stuff
up and the first one that then we get to
play around with in a second and yeah
[Music]
yeah I mean we pull out all the stops
you know if you're making a sequel
demoing I think there has to be some
kind of advancement on the first there
has to be you have to go a bit you know
bigger in a lot of areas and and I don't
think this film is any different you
know and and it just so happens in the
second book there's some big sort of key
events like the masquerade ball and like
Kristin's birthday party and all these
things that are sort of grandiose in
their scale and and so we know we got to
film all of those and and yeah it's fun
because also there's so much of these
movies and it's just a code ni which is
really fun but then it's quite nice
sometimes when we get to like I believe
other people around this you know and
the pressures off us a little bit you
know so that was fun too I mean it's
fantastic being a part of the movie for
me was such a turnaround you know you
know working with a cast was fantastic
and also experiencing you know
life was awesome so I'm happy to be
polish since I'm such a fan of the book
yeah well the fans are fantastic of
course this is such a massive you know
support system that you have to do them
proud so I hope I did just that yes I
mean we got dark I mean Dakota and Jamie
definitely got darker so we'll see how
it goes
I play Mia so luckily I didn't have any
crazy sexy
yeah being a part of the whole thing the
masquerade ball also seen when you know
Jamie you know goes missing and we all
think you know that he's passed away and
we're in the house and we're stressing
out it's real life you know you kind of
have to really manifest that it's really
happening and it's it's just so cool to
see everybody after how hard they will
worked you know that we really just kind
of did it so I think when you're a part
of Fifty Shades you're a part of an
event and it's an erotic event with toys
and romance and that makes it even much
more fun I love our fans beyond I mean
the streets are lined with them there's
screaming they're so excited they can't
wait for Jamie and Dakota to arrive but
I also like that they're very
tongue-in-cheek
they get it they get that you're not
going to take this world so seriously
it's a bit of a fantasy and they get it
you know I think this is the unde is
nice under Ellis story it is the girl
next door who's seemingly average but
then you dress her up and she's come
bomb BAM boom drop-dead gorgeous and she
has her eyes set on the billionaire
naughty boy and she transforms him
through the power of love
I sort of like every girl's Disney Dream
on some level right I really love mama
gray was mama gray was strong and
nurturing and I wanted to provide a
different archetype in this triangle of
women so to speak for him and that's the
archetype that I think is a little bit
more familiar to us to you to me to
other people which is she's a working
woman she's a doctor yes they come from
money but she's charitable and she
adopted this boy and she's loving and I
think
at first I think she was the dress
example of the powerful transformation
possibilities of love I don't think he
would with Ana if he hadn't had mama
gray I mean talk to this about me but
sort of about me I really feel like
that's true that you knew your mom
provides her and things for you and as
the adoptive mom she had a lot to make
up for from his real mom it's so funny
consistent word of a new thing I mean
it's so wild to be able to step into
something I was so curious about it
going in because I just had no idea what
just expect I think I was a little bit
nervous and apprehensive because it was
such a phenomenon but it was great
everyone made it really easy for you
know everyone's really welcoming it was
just a lot of fun yeah that's so into it
I met some of them here tonight it's
wrong I mean I it's something else ours
really knows about that you know
disappointing the fans because I
remember Mike reading Harry Potter and
like any of those themes that you have
such a firm idea of what should be in
your mind and then saying it I was just
worried that I would disappoint people
yeah yeah definitely I mean it's it's
realized visually so it can't help but
be more intense I guess I'm just so
excited to be here we've been working on
you know I got cast more than three
years ago in this so it's so fun to be
like here and celebrating and seeing
everybody it's I'm just thrilled
yeah and I gotta say like some of the
most incredible fans in the world all
over it's amazing how international it
is and that's one of the things I'm like
most proud of being in this film is how
international the fan base is and just
so kind and wonderful yeah so kind I
know earlier I'm saying I'm seeing the
hotel next door and earlier I was coming
through a crowd of fans and you know
they all wanted to take pictures and
stuff and I had to go take a shower and
I liked you guys I have to shout him
sorry they look go-go-go like so kind
I'm like I love you guys like truly
loves
I think this one's gonna be
substantially darker yet honestly I
haven't seen it yet so I'll see you
tonight
which I'm really excited about but
definitely the script and shooting it
it's way darker yeah I have to say the
fans were amazing like as soon as it was
announced they were so welcoming and
even though I'm playing the bad guy and
they're all gonna hate me in a matter of
weeks that they've been really great and
being a and it's all over the world so
it's for me it's quite humbling and I
and I just really appreciate it it's
been a lot of fun yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's uh it's good it's I mean it lives
up to the title it's darker all right
it's uh it's still steaming and it's
still sexy but it's it's a bit of a
thrill ride too
yeah
I was at the masquerade ball and I was
doing this like 360 video thing and it
was a swarm they were following me
around in there first of all they're all
so kind they're respectful and gracious
and they're just having so much fun and
that's the thing I love it's like it
seems like the fandom is just fun and
that what more do you want
and so it's even though I'm playing a
very hated character they've been
they've been really welcoming and
opening and it's and it's all over the
world so it's it's pretty special
I play Roz Bailey I am the CEO of
Christian grace company it's kind of
overwhelming like this is all
overwhelming and I think when I first
got the part it was pretty exciting and
and just amazing kind of like a dream
and then you know you work and you're
you get to meet all the other actors and
it feels like it becomes work and we've
had this like lull and now it's like
building up again and it kind of kind of
robot how big this was like it's kind of
incredible it is it is we have such an
amazing fandom they are like incredibly
dedicated and loving and welcoming and
it's been lovely it's been great I'm
super excited I never know how big it is
until I come to these things and then
sometimes on the social media I'll see
how big this thing really is and it
really is a phenomenon it's just not not
just one film or one book it's literally
a phenomenon
yeah they're super excited as soon as I
got out of my van oh they're super
excited the fans as soon as I got in my
car
they were like Victor I would come here
take a picture and I was like I gotta go
and I'll be back after but even when we
were shooting in Vancouver the love was
always consistent so it was great
[Music]
yeah I haven't seen it that's all I'm
like yeah yeah yeah I think this version
is well I think fifty shades darker is a
lot more edgier than the first one which
is what I really like about it and I
love Eric Johnson he's a fantastic actor
who's playing Jack Hyde he brings such
an edge to it and I've always been a fan
of his and so I think people gonna
really love just not that it's just a
love story but it also has like an
edgier thriller side to it as well it's
good what is love and it's the last
thing you hear when you leave the movie
theater yeah which I was so excited
about because it's it's quite a
questioning song well the title of the
song is a question what is love so it
felt like a really fitting time for it
to come I think because it kind of
leaves me questioning the whole thing it
was exactly for a different scene but it
was so helpful because I was just the
mood was described to me and kind of
what was happening in this moment and it
was actually it was kind of quite a
questioning moment of the film so um
yeah it kind of worked out really well
in the end but yeah I'm feel so lucky to
be able to even write something like the
first movie very much and I like the
whole concept and I read all the books
and I just felt like darka was an
opportunity to really knocked it up
dramatically in terms of their love
story between each other it wasn't just
about a sexual encounter and a
dominant-submissive but in darker their
relationship works out between what
happens in the bedroom and what happens
outside the bedroom in terms of their
equality and stuff and I think it's
really exciting that Dakota
Anastasia comes into her own she becomes
very much more confident in relationship
and the same time very much open to
kind of things that Christian would like
to do in terms of sex play and
role-playing and so I think it becomes a
much more emotional movie I'm happy
about that
yeah yeah there's drama there is a
thriller elements a threat from
Christians past and as well as Anastasia
has a new boss who is maybe not the most
respectable son of a [ __ ] but it all
gets played out and their love hopefully
survives we'll see by the end well it's
fine you know because and I'm respectful
of it because I realized that somehow
Elaine's
Erica hit on something that was
Universal certainly bringing the foreign
box-office and domestic box-office
suggested that and so I bow down to that
and I thought okay she's tapped into
something that's real and true and
psychological and sexual for a lot of
people so I'm gonna take that and go off
with it it's been a huge labor of love
and I'm so excited for everyone to see
this movie I think they're gonna love it
your fans are amazing they are wonderful
they want when they're so supportive and
they're so supported with the cast and
and everybody and it's just a pleasure
to see them we've just come from the
masquerade ball and it was just awesome
absolutely awesome there's a few things
creeping in from Christians paths just
to unsettle everybody so yeah I think
they'll be pleased this a good drama
there's a lot going on and we've got
this thriller element and we've gifted
with an extraordinary cast so it's going
to be fun I think it's going to be a lot
of fun Oh completely I mean I it for me
it was one week Beauty and the Beast
and that was the kind of thought in my
head as it was unrolling and yeah there
is a Cinderella element to it is a fairy
tale a complete fairy tale so yeah I
think people I know it was just you know
it's all it all adds up it's a it's a
sum of its parts really so you can come
along with the fantasy as well and I
think you did that in the books and you
can do that with the movie as well it is
decadent it's fun okay
why not
you